und das wird zweifelsohne so sein dass
auch uns schlechte bilder in den nächten
erhöht werden aber es gehört auch zu
unserer professionalität damit umzugehen
und ich denke noch mehr als an uns
professionelle rettungskräfte die zu
unserer professionalität zählen dass wir
uns öffnen unseren kollegen dass wir das
gespräch suchen dass wenn wir
pathologien krankhaft zeichen an uns
selber entdecken dass wir und dann in
hilfe an hilfe anbieter wenden werden
wir haben sicherlich auch schweres
ertragen
aber wir haben eine kleine rüstungen das
ist unser berufen und wir müssen uns
damit tagtäglich beschäftigen
und wir haben auch infrastrukturen auch
die wir jederzeit zurückkommen können
wenn es uns schlecht geht